depuis 2004 le dépistage organisé du
cancer du sein a été généralisé dans les
yvelines quarante mille dépistages ont
lieu tous les ans grâce à cette antenne
du centre régional de coordination des
dépistages des cancers
un service public qui accompagne les
femmes et l'âge de 50 ans donc on reçoit
notre les femmes reçoivent notre
invitation
elles prennent rendez-vous dans un
centre de radiologie donc nous on
adresse avec l'invitation une liste de
radiologue agréé au dépistage organisé
et les femmes vont passer donc tous les
deux ans si tout se passe bien
une mammographie de dépistage organisé
jusqu'à l'âge de 74 ans les centres de
coordination des dépistages des cancers
est aussi là pour contrôler une deuxième
fois les résultats des mammographies on
reçoit les mammographies après que les
femmes aient répondu à nos invitations
de dépistage organisé et est passé dans
un premier temps leur mammographie dans
un centre de radiologie du département
où d'ailleurs partir du moment les zones
été considéré normal par le premier
lecteur dans le centre d'imagerie elles
viennent à la structure de gestion pour
être lue par un second radiologue avant
d'être retournés aux femmes avec la
conclusion finale
la dizaine de personnes qui travaillent
dans cette structure accompagne donc les
femmes pendant tout le processus de la
sensibilisation de l'importance du
dépistage jusqu'au résultat
au total 250 femmes sont dépistées
positives au cancer du sein chaque année
dans les yvelines
grâce au dépistage généralisé